good morning pretty early took a dog for
a super early walk tried to catch the
sunrise but I think my timing was a
little off and then I missed the sunrise
then the Sun came up and then I tried to
catch it again and well you just saw
what I got I still haven't figured this
thing out let's go upstairs and edit I
still can't get her but my rooms in the
garage I guess I'll try to get another
time-lapse I tried and I just didn't
look very good let's try again from up
here
I bet that look dumb - hey little
Explorer the slice is so cute and so
dog-friendly they even have like a
little gate over here so that you can
block it off so the dogs don't go and
roam out into the forest or the street
she gonna be trying to learn how to use
cameras time for breakfast we're gonna
make french toast and scrambled eggs
what a delicious treat hi sorry
little lazy boy what you're a tester
well I'm not sure I was gonna taste
because yeah I wasn't really trying to
put like vanilla in a minute we don't
have any milk need to put some milk in
them but haven't you we forgot it
yesterday if we make sure that like it's
a blackout day really I'm gonna go fly
the drone if you want to say hi to it
from up here you know you don't have to
see I was just saying if you happen to
see it okay tend to fly the drone this
is gonna be pretty ballsy because
there's not much room to take off or
land here so I'm gonna have to be extra
precise so we know how I am about
precision dogs trying to come out oh
there's a lot of people over there now
where did they come from I think one of
the things that I love about flying
drones is it can be a little bit
challenging at times but I love the
perspective it gives you such an
incredible perspective not only just in
your scenery but I feel like for me on
my entire life because it just shows you
how insignificant we all really are but
yet one person can make quite the impact
depending upon if you actually give a
crap or not so maybe you should give
more craps then you'll make a bigger
impact I mean this is I got it I should
take it down there I'm gonna be I don't
want to be irresponsible or do i I don't
because I only have one drone I'm gonna
be responsible and I'm gonna take this
down some of you might be wondering
Justine raise your Mavic act the Mavic
that I had it previously wasn't mine it
was still DJ eyes so I've been waiting
oh no hi it's down here so I've been
waiting for mine to ship but it still
hasn't shipped yet so I'm back with my
phantom but you know either way I
absolutely love the Phantom and I'm so
excited to try out the Phantom 4 Pro
this is like a fake Beach like this used
to be clearly a lake and it's now the
riverbed
yes looks good always calibrate
I'm gonna sit down house it for this
oh yeah that was great
hey where we going guys going on a walk
how are we going for a walk if we're
driving or driving to the trail Oh Steph
that's not Zhanna left so
huh appeared that he was overlooked
found the hike we also found some snow
this isn't like a hard trail right Jen
no probably should wore some boots so I
got my uggs on
oh boy oh gosh
nice I'm gonna have to snap the rest of
this because I can't film with my big
camera cuz the dog he's going nuts he's
seeing snow so pretty
you gotta get back up here honey
I'm so stressed out here you want the
stick good sit
behave yourself that's what we use a V
doesn't have a treat cool shall I
continue we got some great pictures I
think you on the hook let's roll any
hike should we go back down or should I
keep calling I didn't say nothing
Maddie's eating a stick it's like he's
never been outside oh geez oh my god
this is how we get him to be good boy
Manny that's sick sit good sit
Maddie just do gymnastics Oh time to
drone the lighting is so perfect right
now and Edie is bringing out his Mavic
so we're gonna have a little drone party
it's gonna be great about to get our
drone on this is such a perfect room
spot I'm always one step behind wishing
I could read your mind but I'm ready
yeah never a day wish I can
yeah
Edd's got the mamak and i'm gonna get a
sweet overhead shot of you opening this
thing up oh my god it looks so good God
my battery is at like 99 person mines at
I should probably grab another battery
Rome race he just took his Mavic out of
the inter mode and we're about to race
across the water it says that my speed
will be substantially increased Siri
what's the temperature so let's see
just
I let the story tell me what
you ever wonder
I wish
you say
hydro getting a cool shot of it going
backwards out but I can't calibrate it
here so I'm gonna go down there take off
calibrate